this video is brought to you by Wix
what's up guys
Michael here I have a question when's
the last time you went to the movies
specifically to see a comedy what about
a rom-com killing most Americans it's
probably been a minute people in general
are skipping out on your classic phoney
bone tickling films and comedies that
succeed at the box office are becoming
the exception rather than the rule we're
seeing lots of comedies flounder this
year from book smart to the beach bum to
the longshot to late night and on and on
and on even men in black international
only pulled in 250 million a pale
comparison to the 624 million its
predecessor men in black 3 mate
indeed you could almost hear the
industry free the collective sigh of
relief when the recent comedy good boys
hit 21 million in its opening weekend
making it one of only two comedies hit
number one in the box office this year
comscore media analyst Paul Durr
Garabedian summed up the situation
saying this is like a unicorn sighting
even so only 1 million is a sum that
probably wouldn't have even made us
blink circa the summer of 2009 when the
hangover pulled in a cool 45 million
during its opening weekend if you scan a
list of top performing films of the late
90s or even the early to mid arts a
whole lot of them are comedies what
happened the days when Austin Powers
ruled a box office where's our 2019
pretty woman and just for argument's
sake why no hangover for the truth is
traditional film subgenres like the
rom-com or those gross-out comedies the
1990s seemed about as culturally
relevant as a late-night saw cop at a
high school gymnasium but before you
grab that comedy shaped casket from your
closet let's look a little closer is
comedy really dead what if it never even
existed in the first place let's find
out in this wisecrack edition on the
maybe death of comedy but before we get
into that I want even shoutout to this
week's sponsor wicks
with wicks you can create your own
unique website perfect for any occasion
whether you're planning your wedding and
building a personal portfolio or
launching an online store Wix has
everything you need to create a
functioning masterpiece with which you
can share photos and videos and even
host music connect your socials and add
all kinds of tools that will make your
website professional and robust
once you're set up Wix will give you
access to all your analytics so you can
see where your site's traffic is coming
from and so
much more and if you upgrade two weeks
premium you can get unlimited bandwidth
and access to VIP priority support
create your own unique website today by
clicking here or going to Wix comm
select wisecrack and get 15% off all
yearly plans by using promo code
wisecrack 15 now back to the show
we think a quick recap the current
comedy landscape is an order news
outlets like The Hollywood Reporter have
made a habit of sounding the alarm about
the death of comedy films we're treated
to ever more dire statistics showing
comedic box-office flops and we're
seeing fewer total laugh out loud
comedies total box-office revenue for
comedies shrink from 2.5 billion in 2009
to just 1 billion in 2018 and 2018
comedies accounted for just 7.2 percent
of all domestic box-office revenue so
what made traditional comedy films and
endangered species the easy answer might
be the ever-expanding number of
streaming services but the real answer
is a little more complicated also it
involves China as you presumably a human
being watching YouTube certainly know
consumers have more entertainment
options than ever before you can stream
anything your heart desires on 10
different competing platforms or watch
your best to eat Tide Pods on YouTube
note that these alternatives are
typically cheaper than a movie ticket
and how does a studio deal with the
competition from all these sick tik-tok
compilations they're going international
or at least more international studios
are coping with domestic losses by
trying to maximize their profits in
places like China Japan India France
indeed in 2018 Warner Brothers earned
just 1.9 billion dollars in North
America compared to a hefty three point
six billion dollars overseas across the
board international audiences are
blooming and the Motion Picture
Association of America predicts that
China will soon overtake the US as the
largest movie market in the world but
how does one make an American film with
widespread international appeal it's not
necessarily meg Ryan really enjoying the
sandwich what she's having
instead it's usually fast cars big guns
and a superhero or two or three or ten
indeed comic book films and action
flicks are a perfect fit for the
international audience as they peddle
largely in special effects that can be
appreciated regardless
of your language or culture as non
dialogue heavy films they also require
less pesky dubbing your subtitles while
offering the universal appeal of
watching blow up in contrast comedies
are not as easy to pour over to a
Bangladeshi theatre if the hotel a
captain we've got to land as soon as we
can this woman has to be gotten to a
hospital hospital it's a big building
with patients but that's not important
right now
that's because comedies rely a lot on
cultural specificity just thinking about
how different the British office is from
its American counterpart coughs my man
immediately beneath me Oh as an actor
said to a bishop now he's no you always
loved me satisfied in smiling or how the
show also spawned iterations in places
like India Chile and Finland all with
their own cultural quirks you're still
thinking comedy can transcend
international borders no problem Pete
this Chinese comedy god of cookery if
you're not from China is this funny of
you probably not the rock breaking out
of a cast with his bicep might be
universal but it's hard to make a comedy
that really appeals to the international
masses thus Studios aren't really
investing in developing new comedy
scripts the way that they used to Judd
Apatow the literal creator of the modern
for assembly line of comedies echoes a
swordsman telling indieWIRE that comedy
film basically died after the last
writer's strike which ended in 2008
Apatow says I feel like the studio's
don't buy as many scripts now as a
result a lot of great comedy writers are
going to television instead so there you
have it our investigation comes to a
close say goodbye to all your favorite
forms of comedy from star vehicles for
people like Will Ferrell and Meg Ryan to
quality parodies like scary movie to
delightful gross-out comedies like
there's something about Mary instead if
you feel like laughing looks like you're
going to have to stick to tick-tock the
way what about this as far as I'm
concerned that's America's s that line
brought the house down or take this
moment from get out I'm TS mother [ __ ]
a
we handle it's genuinely funny right
indeed comedian Jordan peels seamless
transition into the horror genre hasn't
stopped him from showcasing his sense of
humor even though we're buying a ticket
to see a horror film
we also walk in pretty sure that
something's going to make us laugh by
the way I would have voted for Obama for
a third term if I could has comedy just
undergone some kind of metamorphosis to
understand the comic forces at play in a
Marvel movie like endgame or a horror
film like get out we'll need to take a
look at the film scholar Jeff King in
his book film comedy king basically says
that the term comedy can't be fully
understood as just a genre arguing that
it is so widespread as to be difficult
to locate as a single or stable generic
form instead you suggest looking at
comedy as a mode but what's a mode and
how is it different than a genre simply
put a genre is a category of film take
for example the Western nearly all films
within a genre will share certain
essential narratives characters or other
features like setting westerns typically
have a rugged cowboy and expansive dusty
American landscape and aesthetically an
appealing villain and some form of a
gunfight both the classic high noon and
the unclassified Wild West share these
features and thus both are westerns in
contrast a mode is a manner of
presentation it's a mood or feeling and
all the choices that contribute to that
mood it's helpful here to think of how
mode works in music a musical mode is a
scale with specific notes and melodic
features take the Dorian mode made up of
these notes arranged in this manner both
the traditional hymn drunken sailor
and the Latin jazz song oil komova are
written in the Dorian mode though the
two songs belong to radically different
genres
similarly in film both Shazam and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood use a comedic
mode though the former is also a
superhero flick and the latter is also a
thriller in drama got it
so Kings argument goes because any genre
may be treated as a subject for comedy
it's more accurate to see it as a mode a
modifier of other genres rather than
simply one in its own right
while film comedy was published back in
2002 we'd argue that Kings Point offers
a lens to look at comedy that is even
more relevant today
your comedy movies are made than ever
before and the ones that are made fail
at the box-office but we might still
laugh at the movies just as much so
Kings diagnosis of comedy as more of a
mode than a genre rings truer than ever
before but how exactly does this mode of
comedy manifest in movies at first
glance that seems simple comedy is what
makes you laugh the next 9/11 is gonna
be able to geriatrics
but what if say in the cinematic
masterpiece the room the filmmaker
wasn't trying to make you laugh yeah and
what if a comedy film like that Santa
doesn't make you laugh even though it's
trying to it's more complicated than
just eliciting a laugh it needs to be
intentional King expands his definition
of comedy and film as a mode that tends
to involve departures from what are
considered to be the normal routines of
life of the social group in question
take a normal situation you're at a
grocery store then add a departure from
your norm you're wearing a bathrobe and
sandals it have to write a check for 69
cents tada
you have comedy the form of comedy can
vary it can result from incongruity like
a superhero hanging out in a convenience
store
or it can result from exaggeration like
the dad's over-the-top to tempt to sound
like a tough guy in US so if you all
want to get crazy we can get crazy
ultimately King says comedy results from
a sense of things being out of place
mixed up or not quite right furthermore
modality isn't just in the tone of the
words being spoken or images being shown
King notes that modality can be complex
and multi-dimensional and include
elements like the use of music sound or
opening sequences Princeton
we see how music is used when Alison
Williams character hilariously drinks a
glass of milk segregated from a bowl of
Froot Loops while listening to the song
I've had the time of my life both sound
and even the use of color a phony in
context the cheery tune calls attention
to the incongruity of a diabolical
character drinking a wholesome glass of
milk while literally looking for the
next Mart for her parents weirdo gang of
brain swapping yuppies the same time the
flat-out bizarre method of cereal
consumption defies common sense
seriously she doesn't even eat an entire
fruit loop in one bite or let's look at
how characters narrative and tone can
combine to create a comedic mode take
the opening scene of last year's
Halloween reboot which a couple of true
crime podcasters attempt to interview
Michael Myers all sequence is full of
self-aware commentary on true crime
culture and the commodification of
popular criminal personalities we're
we're making a podcast you can see the
modality of comedy working its way in
even as the film prepares us for lots of
bloodshed and of course we can't talk
about modern comedy without dealing with
Marvel which has basically turned the
superhero film into a debatably
knee-slapping community experience with
silly one-liners and you did a Banksy at
the crime scene just for us absurd
situations good because we blow the grid
I don't want to lose a tiny here in the
1950s excuse me
and all the self-aware humor you could
want nude monster hey Thor again you
know the god of thunder listen buddy if
you don't log off this game immediately
I'm gonna fly over to your house come
down to that basement you're hiding in
rip off your arms and shove them up your
butt now one caveat we think it's
reasonable to assume that in simpler
times of filmmaking it would have made
more sense to view comedy as a genre
that's because before the late 1950s
bills typically conformed pretty neatly
into defined categories and we're less
likely to borrow from one another it was
unlikely that you would see a sci-fi
drama like a rival or a phony drama like
Juna wicked Tiger looks proud as a
result comedy may have acted more like a
consistent genre and less like a mode
but today we're seeing John Orr's become
increasingly more unstable just
because we're in our rims doesn't mean
more sleeping fine I don't know goodbye
Jeremy guys we have to be out here at 10
a.m. tomorrow sharp so hello oh my god
indeed films today are more likely to
take a buffet-style approach to genre
oftentimes these are used to appeal to
more media savvy audiences who have come
to recognize tropes in a more conscious
way as this happens we see comedy
becoming almost like ambient background
music once we start thinking of comedy
as mode rather than a genre it becomes
clear that our comic sensibilities are
not only alive but perhaps even thriving
with the world and ever larger dumpster
fire maybe we're in need of a laugh more
than ever even if we're not seeking in
the form of a washed-up newscaster and
is accidental for fantasy go [ __ ]
yourself San Diego and of course if
you're looking for a laugh just turn on
a TV where comedy is more than alive and
well in the form of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
South Park Rick and Morty Bojack
horseman Silicon Valley and on and on
and on even still we'd say comedy is
also surviving on the big screen as a
mode and if you agree with King that's
all it ever was in the first place so
what do you guys think it's comedy and
film deader than Uncle Ben after another
Spiderman reboot or totally alive and
well in unexpected ways and for gosh
sake watch your language that's not
going away anytime soon are you diggin
Jordan peels brave new world of horror
comedies or do you miss the days of Tom
Cruise running a brothel and risky
business let us know in the comments and
a big thanks to all our dope patrons who
support the channel on our podcast don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
before you go I want to give another
shout out to Wix with wix's premium
plans you can connect your own domain
and get 20 gigabytes of storage
unlimited bandwidth and so much more
create your own unique website today by
going to wix.com slash wisecracks and
get 15% off all yearly plans by using
promo code wisecrack 15 thanks for
watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]